sometimes I stayed up all right cuz I
was scared to go to sleep cuz I didn't
know if I wake up I had to come to town
as quick that I could die he's the
hardest-working kid I know
he's just a different kind of animal
started playing football he was like
seven I knew right away that's what I
like to do the most football was it a
plan I wanted to try to get a college
scholarship if somebody were to take
that away he would be crushing to him
and May 2015
Oh Myron felt it he started having
fevers he complained of neck and back
pain he got worse
every day to the point like a bear like
walked it wasn't a dead sweat his mom it
took his temperature and he she realized
that it was no 104 you're like my mom
was like that's it you gotta go to the
doctor
we arrived in Arkansas Children's
Hospital straight to the emergency room
they took us in did a number of blood
tests and then it was like like a really
big group of people that walked in and
you could tell that nobody nobody out of
that group wanted to tell me I can't
remember what he looked like he told me
he was like hey we found blood cells I
was like okay what does that mean he was
like that means you have leukemia
[Music]
he was diagnosed with acute myeloid
leukemia it starts off with just one
cell in his bone marrow for whatever
reason there was a mutation and it
continued to replicate and replicate it
was basically overtaking his body this
cannot be true because he was doing well
he was getting serious about his future
and it's like you're driving down the
highway listening to your tunes sunny
days sunroof open and bang you had
treatment it's in the middle of the road
and you can't afford it that's how it
was what if my child dies what am I
gonna do first I was a little
disappointed because I put in a lot of
work to get in good shape you know felt
like it was taken away and then and I
felt fear because I didn't know those
names the things in life all of a sudden
shift from I want to be a good football
player too you know I want to survive
over following six months Omari had four
surgeries nine bone marrow biopsies six
spinal taps he just been laying there
you know like you know he couldn't talk
because he was going through like so
much pain 52 days of various antibiotics
47 blood transfusions about a hundred
and sixty-eight total doses of
chemotherapy I just thought like why him
why would you do something to somebody
working that hard he spent about a
hundred and sixteen days in the hospital
the hardest days were always here in the
news that I wouldn't be able to go home
because you look for it you look for
good news you don't get any from the
doctors you can't move
okay me and there were some days I just
got like really depressed and I pray a
lot cuz I didn't I didn't know what else
to do I pray for strength food
patience because I found myself rushing
a lot to try to go to the hospital and
wisdom to you know try to handle this
better
[Music]
with the Lord being strong
I knew that he'll find a way to come out
Omari finished up his treatments in
December we were dismissed they had told
him that he was in remission but you
know they have to keep with the rounds
in order to try to make sure that it
does not return a lot of people who
don't make it and if you look back you
know you realize that you're really
really blessed to to come out of
something like that you know and still
be able to do what you what you love to
do you know play football I think
football was a great motivator in his
mind because I think always in the back
of his mind he always thought I'm gonna
get through this and I'm gonna get back
playing yeah after their mission
announcement football was the next thing
on my mind I tried to give back get back
to the gym as soon as I could just stuff
to try to get active again because I've
been laying around for so long he's
doing great
there's no signs or evidence of relapse
and his heart's doing good and Audia
doing good clients doing good goals
going forward to play Division one
football it doesn't matter where it
doesn't matter who I just know that I
want to get the team give it to you the
best of me
also want to start like a charity
foundation for pediatric cancer it's in
the works
he's in a good place you can see did he
don't know exactly where he's going but
he know he's going somewhere you know
and he feels that if he can overcome the
situation like this that he can overcome
anything
[Music]